bien très bien
marc-antoine il paraît qu'on peut
prendre des nouvelles de jean claude van
damme hockey bonjour envoie ses bientôt
l'automne c'est super on va pouvoir
skier
on chante et on se prend plus tard ok
alors le film ton film baptiste say
libre et assoupi ok mais s'était assoupi
c'est que tu dors donc si ça se trouve
tu rêves que tu es libre mais c'est pas
vrai je ne l'avais imaginé valérie si ça
se trouve on est dans le rêve de
quelqu'un depuis le début quoi moi nous
on n'existe pas on a des personnes
imaginaire ya un oiseau qu'est ce que je
disais moi je sais plus moi je fais du
karaté est vrai que du karaté je suis
libre et assouplit assouplies tu as
compris à venir
et et jean reno va bien jean reno
bonjour à tous j'ai adoré libre et
supplie parce que le but du et vous
c'est d'en faire le moins possible comme
moi quand je joue regarde baptiste
présent de la graine le rire ou la la
qu'est-ce que c'est marrant c'est
vraiment hilarant tiens j'ai un fou rire
hein lol et maintenant la tristesse au
nom mon dieu qu'est-ce que je suis
triste c'est vraiment bouleversant
d'ailleurs je pleure ouais ouais
françois savard ces fonds soient
plusieurs bombes à cuche
non c'est pas mal ton film là mais c'est
un peu à du plagiat quand même on attend
maintenant plus un type qui bouge pas a
poussé par un ami c'est déjà le concept
d'un touche à deux mains dans bon
j'espère quand même que votre film et
marchera aussi bien que le nôtre tout ce
que tu en penses omar du duvet les rues
couture est dû on a fait une soirée
colocation je peux dire qu'il y avait
plusieurs l'intérieur
je veux croire ron des nouvelles d'un
chanteur qu'on aime beaucoup christophe
maé je suis bloqué quelque temps sur
tout le monde sait qu'en film moi je
trouve super parce que vos personnages
hissant times tendeng d'un en plus ça
montre bien les problèmes qu'il y a dans
la colocation et parce que on s'attache
et au säntis zone non non j'entends
bloqué mais bon niveau 5 être sdf et
vivre dans la rue parce que ça fait mal
a dit voix sans toi
j'aimerais qu'on prend des coups de
quelqu'un qu'on vénère tous ici et
s'allumer petite beauté
je vous dire monsieur louis valéry elle
est magnifique c'est ma préférée
bon j'adore j'adore je vous dis comme ça
baptiste il est magnifique c'est mon
préféré
jadore jadore jadore jean-michel et non
pas toi
le gars en tout cas chez vous dire ma
vie ma vie c'est enfin enfin je veux
dire ton film c'est comme ma vie un oui
parce que moi je cohabite avec des cas
un peu particulier je vais vous dire il
s'appelle morini bosc et raconte une
anecdote ça dure une heure et demie elle
est libre et nous on dit j'ai
complètement raté pas mal mais je